ثلاثه ايام من المناورات العسكريه
بالذخيره الحيه حول تايوان وصلت الى
نهايتها بعد ان اعلنت بكين اختتاما
المناورات ومع اعلان نهايه التدريبات اكدت
الصين انها ستمنع استقلال تايوان وكل
محاولات التدخل الخارجي في الجزيره التي
تعتبرها الصين جزءا منها تسعى لاستعادته
بالقوه اللازمه الامر الصين قالت ان
المناورات كانت رساله تحذير الى الجزيره
السعيه للاستقلال في تحرك لاق انتقادات
واسعه من واشنطن وقبل اختتام المناورات
كان متحدث باسم وزارات الخارجيه الصينيه
اعتبر ان التدريبات في مضيق تايوان رساله
تحذير لمن اسماهم بالانفصاليين مؤكدا ان
استقلال تايوان ودعم القوى الخارجيه اكبر
تهديد للسلام في المنطقه على حد قوله
الجيش الصيني كان اجرى تدريبات بالذخيره
الحيه في مضيق تايوان تحاكي
طوق حول الجزيره بما في ذلك فرض حصار جوي
يشار الى ان المناورات التي بدات السبت
جاءت احتجاجا على لقاء جمع الاربعاء في
كاليفورنيا رئيسه تايوان ساي انجوان مع
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن وكان اخر
انتشار كبير حول الجزيره حصل في اغسطس
الماضي مع مناورات عسكريه صينيه غير
مسبوقه ردا على زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي حينها نانسي بلوسي بشكل عام تنظر
الصين باستياء الى التقارب الذي حدث في
السنوات الاخيره بين السلطات التايوانيه
والولايات المتحده التي توفر للجزيره دعما
عسكريا كبيرا رغم عدم وجود علاقات رسميه
بين الطرفين
تايوان من جانبها قالت بعد انهاء الجيش
الصيني مناوراته العسكريه حول الجزيره ان
الصين تقود الامن والسلامه في المنطقه
واكد المتحدث باسم وزارات الدفاع على ان
القوات التايوانيه في حاله تاهب قصوى
للحفاظ على الامن القومي بطريقه عقلانيه
على حد قوله
لتصعيد الموقف ستحافظ قواتنا على سيادتنا
وامننا القومي بطريقه رصينه وعقلانيه
ومدروسه في غضون ذلك ظلت وحده دفاعنا
الجوي في حاله تاهب قصوى انهم يراقبون عن
كثب كل هدف محتمل ويستجيبون لحاله الطوارئ
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه قامت ايضا بنشر
لقطات تظهر الاستعدادات العسكريه التي
تقوم بها في ظل المناورات العسكريه
الصينيه لمحاكاه الضربات على تايوان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات